they've been waiting for this day to
come for 18 months the halal wheeze are
here to pick up their grandmother a
yoosh she's scheduled to arrive any
minute now from Syria via Beirut to
Berlin I'm so excited I couldn't sleep
all night I'm so anxious
the theater the halawi Tsar lucky
they've been able to bring grandmother
are used to Germany thanks to the
sponsorship program that helped Syrian
refugees in Germany retreat family
members still stuck in the war-torn
country
there's no other way that could have
done this that's why this moment is
bittersweet
while we were able to retrieve one
person we have to leave many behind we
can only focus on the worst cases six
weeks earlier and make a break meeting
at the foreigners office in Berlin matin
coin oh the aid organizations chairman
has organized a so-called declaration of
commitment this local sponsor seals the
deal with her signature pledging that
she not the German government will cover
any unexpected costs this is the only
way Germany can afford to retrieve the
sick and elderly from Syria what are her
living conditions like at the moment was
her house bombed my grandmother's house
is in ruins she lives in our old house
now she can't make it on her own that's
why we want to bring her to Germany
health is deteriorating as well thanks
to the aid organizations efforts
200 Syrians now enjoy safety in Germany
the Holloway's fled their home country
three years ago today their children go
to school in Berlin their eldest son is
doing an apprenticeship hello mum how
are you mum at 76 years old I use
couldn't possibly have made the arduous
journey along the Balkan route most of
the Syrian refugees travelled to get to
Germany but staying in Aleppo isn't an
option she desperately needs surgery she
has no money no neighbors to help make
sure she takes her medication where it
gets help she doesn't even have
electricity all she has is a candle I
miss my grandmother I hope she can come
to Germany I haven't seen her in so long
I miss her
[Music]
it's way past midnight at Berlin Airport
I use plane from Beirut has been delayed
but after an unbearable weight it
finally arrives
[Music]
this is the farthest the 76 year-old has
ever been from Syria
and yet surrounded by her family for the
first time in three years she's finally
home